as you wander down the aisles of the
grocery store you might find your
attention caught on any number of things
frozen pizza cupcakes wine and as
delicious as all of those things are we
doubt that any of them undergoes as
spectacular of a transformation as a
packet of instant yeast does when you
shoot lasers at it
because that is not how yeast always
looks in the packet it's dry and dull
and when you add water and look at it
under a microscope without any lasers
added yeast are more like stagnant
sturdy living bubbles so what makes
yeast shine so bright when hit with a
laser well we will get there but first
let's talk about the grocery store and
why you can buy a packet full of
microbes while you are there because
that is where James our master of
microscopes our purveyor of ponds got
these yeast he bought them in the form
of instant yeast that was sitting on the
shelf of a supermarket and that's
because for most of us yeast is an
ingredient it's something a recipe calls
for like milk or sugar but yeast is also
something much more than an ingredient
it's more like an ally a friendly Baker
on the inside who does so much of the
work for us as long as we give it a few
things in exchange when you buy a packet
of instant yeast what you are actually
buying is a lot of saccharomyces
cerevisiai that's the name of the
species and it roughly translates to
Sweet fungus of beer but it's known by
many other names like brewer's yeast
baker's yeast and budding yeast but
those first two names are a tribute to
the role yeast play in helping make our
beer wine and what we're going to focus
on today bread if you've used instant
yeast you've probably conjure up the
image of the tiny brownish white
granules that filled the packet in froth
up when you add water those granules are
full of live yeast that have been dried
out for later use and their small size
is important it gives each of those
minuscule yeast clumps more surface area
relative to their volume helping them
dissolve faster when they are mixed with
liquid and hydrated into something that
looks more like these cells James is a
master of microscopes not a baker so he
wasn't planning to use these yeasts to
make bread but yeast of course helps us
make bread using these same basic
processes that helps them survive so the
steps James took to bring these cells to
life can help us see some of the
ingredients and processes that make our
favorite loaves possible starting out
with sugar
we often describe the size of microbes
as fractions of fractions of millimeters
but it can be tough to wrap our minds
around what that really means looking at
these yeast cells dwarfed by a few
undissolved grains of sugar helps give a
better sense of scale just think of how
small a grain of sugar is in your hand
and imagine just how much tinier a
little yeast must be again it's easy to
think of sugar and yeast as two
ingredients in bread one added after to
make the right bit of chemistry happen
and while that's true there's also a
little more going on sugar is like a
bribe that helps kick-start our yeast
friends into action giving them the
sustenance they need to get moving as
the yeast feeds they begin to divide
forming smaller daughter cells that bud
off from their mothers you can see some
of those buds here forming ovals that
Branch off the circular Mother cell this
is where the name Buddy
comes from and it is yet another way
that yeast is different from our other
ingredients sugar doesn't make more
sugar but for yeast replication is one
of their objectives driving the growth
and survival of their population but as
the yeast accomplishes their goals they
happen to get some of our goals done as
well as the yeast digests sugar they
produce byproducts various organic acids
ethanol and carbon dioxide which you can
see here in bubbles expanding and
pushing against the field of yeast we
are watching these bubbles grow in water
and over the next few minutes their
edges will push further and further out
until these two bubbles seem to take
over the screen but in bread dough those
carbon dioxide bubbles cause the entire
structure around the yeast to expand and
to rise and when the dough is moved into
the oven the carbon dioxide will shape
the bread that forms the ethanol
byproduct isn't visible like those
carbon dioxide bubbles are but in bread
dough the evaporation of ethanol also
helps the bread rise in the oven and it
will also shape the flavor of the bread
that comes out
while it is making bread for us the
world inside the yeast is busy as well
buried in dough it's impossible to see
what that means but microscopes are
powerful tools when it comes to digging
up seemingly invisible forms of beauty
especially when they have lasers in them
with a microscope that sends a laser of
UV light straight at the yeast molecules
inside the organism begin to fluoresce a
display called autofluorescence that
lights up the whole screen with rings of
red and green and yellow that press up
against each other and overlap
to scientists who know how to crack the
code those colors create a map of the
molecules inside the cell those colors
are actually the amino acids and
vitamins that make the yeast work rising
and falling throughout the yeast's life
cycle to provide the organism with what
it needs to survive it's as if someone
turned on the lights at the factory
Illuminating all of the processes that
make the final product possible and if
we could dedicate a whole episode to
these stunning Auto fluorescing patterns
of yeast we would but there's one big
challenge you may have noticed that the
videos we've been showing of this are
pretty short most only last a few
seconds before we switch to another
video and that is because those Bright
Lights quickly fade after being struck
with the laser let's sit here and watch
this group of yeast initially bright red
and green after only a few seconds the
red is already gone
[Music]
and as more seconds pass the green
becomes more and more faint like someone
has been turning the brightness on your
screen down at an agonizingly slow pace
[Music]
foreign
the screen has gone completely black
with no hint at the Vivid scene painted
across it so recently almost as if it
had never been there to begin with but
even as the lights fade the factory
remains every day perhaps in your
kitchen or in the bakery around the
corner from you there is a group of
invisible budding Bakers occupied with
turning sugar into carbon dioxide and
ethanol however transient their lives or
their work the Legacy they leave well
there's no arguing with that
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us the people you're
seeing on the screen right now those are
our patreon patrons they're the ones who
make it possible for us to get the yeast
packet which aren't that expensive but
also so that we have access to the
lasers which are actually not that cheap
if you would like to become a patron on
patreon you can go to patreon.com
journey to micro there you can get a
bunch of cool perks and also just know
that you're making it possible for this
to exist if you'd like to see more from
our master of microscopes James Weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]